the best songs the ones that you write
in a couple hours yes so when you wrote
uh I don't know if you wrote Vogue or
somebody a couple hours couple hours
where are you when you come up with the
idea of vote you're in a club obviously
right and you see people voguing
no I I'd seen people voting and then I
had to write a song for um and I thought
it was a really cool dance very
presentational and elegant and all about
vanity and
and then Warren asked me to write a song
for Dick Tracy and then I was thinking
about all the movie stars it was the
thing about Warren is that he grew up in
that era you know he knew and well he
dated all of Hollywood basically
um is that freaky dating a guy who's
basically dated everyone I I enjoyed it
actually because I was he an incredible
lover because he was supposed to be
yes he was
I'm not gonna lie but he I would say
things like what what was it like what
was Julie Christie like what was Natalie
Wood like what was you mean really he
was with such amazing women you would
say that to him yeah because I think
most women don't want to know it just
feels like kind of weird yeah I looked
up to them and admired them but isn't
that like bragging to your girlfriend
about no I asked the question he didn't
bring it up I asked him I wanted him to
tell me did you ever say it again my
better in bed with than Julie Christie
because no I didn't say that right um I
have confidence in my skills I'm sure
you do but I I wanted to know what they
were like as people not lovers right and
it could they were they're all very
accomplished talented remarkable women
was Warren your best lover
oh gosh
it sounds like a yes I'm not going to
answer that question oh come on no I'm
not I played the fifth in here I'm not
I'm pleading the fifth
cause who's the best I mean there's lots
of lots some people are technically good
but if you don't feel anything good
about them no you have to look they
can't be purely sexual no you have to
have feelings yeah true right well
anyways so that's so that song actually
was a a process it was a little bit of a
process thinking about how I'm going to
work this into the Dick Tracy thing and
like you know the voguing thing and you
know so that took me more than a minute
laughs